l'essence de la télévision en troisième
chaîne première fois
voilà voilà ce que c'est la troisième
chaîne juste avant la troisième chef
sait peu de choses finalement peut même
dire que c'est rien du tout rien du tout
bien que les ondes de monsieur hertz et
de monsieur maxwell qui courent dans
tous les sens demandent les voit pas ça
ne vous fait pas froid dans le dos cette
troisième chaîne privée de 3ème chaîne
si bien sûr on va voir qui c'est
peut-être le moment le plus exaltant de
son histoire commença donc une déception
que la faux pas pas de critique par
l'ombre de téléspectateurs courroucé
noter que c'était les spectateurs là
serait ingrat parce que en janvier il a
versé pour deux chaînes et on lui en
donne une troisième avant la fin de
l'année pour l'instant c'est le paradis
c'est c'est la béatitude
oui dit on va pas rester dans la
béatitude désertique jusqu'à demain on
avait raison et je crois qu'il est temps
de meubler ce froid décor mur apprentis
sorciers dit dans l'arène
je vais essayer seul s'amusant un pote
ça va mieux un haut sens vraiment chez
soi oui oh rien n'est non indispensables
ou là et bien qu'est ce que c'est que ce
poisson rouge
ah ça c'est pour les interludes de pour
les interviews syndiqués sûrement mais
aucun doute on est vraiment sur une
chaîne de télé oui mais il ya quelque
chose qui me tracasse oui quoi les
téléspectateurs qui viennent d'ouvrir
leur poste à l'instant même
ils savent pas ce qu'ils sont en train
de voir c'est vrai elle a peut-être
qu'ils s'imaginent qu'ils sont sur la
première sur la deuxième chaîne
quelle horreur si on faisait un petit
bis de l'ouverture les raisons on ne
fait jamais trop bien les choses
merci mes sens de la troisième chaîne de
télévision deuxièmement
mais
vous ne trouvez pas quand même que
jusqu'à présent cette troisième chaîne
ressemble terriblement aux deux
premières crois que vous avez raison il
manque deux choses
le champagne est la marraine nettement à
la marraine mais c'est très délicat déjà
le champagne non c'est la marraine la
plus importante en voyons alors comment
vous la voyez vous la marraine de la
troisième chaîne la marraine de la
troisième chaîne
moi je sais pas je la vois charmante pis
quand je la vois c'est pas ça du tout
c'est pas ça du tout tv plupart du tout
bon alors je recommence
non c'est mieux et mieux c'est déjà vu
sur les deux autres chaînes mais à bord
bon alors je me concentre et sinon moi
vous
mais metz et anne marie david oui c'est
la marraine de la troisième chaîne oui
bonsoir anne marie david marine de la
troisième chaîne
bonsoir à tous et ce cadeau aux abords
des voies votre filleul une chanson qui
naîtra ce soir comme la troisième chaîne
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez ma
marraine je veux dire je n'aurais pas
mieux fait moi même
m
c'est quand même à 2
j'ai quand même
à 2
qu'on aime
c'est quand
on est mieux
non
en ouvrant allait bien on entend
celui camp
tu t'es bien
qui
plein
cronje
mais [ __ ]
mais pour
volley
pas vous
au fond
on va voir
on ma
sinon
on oublie le temps
t
on sait
ça
ce serait
ouais
i
c'est en main
a2 a23
tu sais quand maman
on est bien
aussi je ne crois
tu es trop tôt
on est trois
m
lorsque vous
c'est
quand on devient
c'est à
je donne deux
ça
c
germa rennes voulez-vous baptisé
officiellement notre troisième show
commence là et bien c'est très simple
en vous saisissant de cette bouteille de
jean bad travaux de marque d'ailleurs et
en la brisant sur cette mesure
symbolique et que va-t-il se passer
après il se passera que notre chaîne qui
vient de naître sera baptisé
officiellement troisième du nom voilà
tout est prêt derrière vous êtes sûr
naturellement tout après quelques
questions toujours la même chose alors
regardez moi ce gâchis va faire la
balayer tout ça maintenant
vous avez vu ma bosse il n'y a pas de
doute la troisième scène ça va être un
booster ses 106 ans a frappé pour moi
disait monsieur général non monsieur
directeur général par hassen général de
directeur non c'est un directeur général
quelle est la différence la différence
c'est qu'en général on dirait directeur
général audibert et leurs directeurs et
sous-directeurs est en général honnête
en civil à 100 générale en syrie
nora directeur général n'est pas un
militaire alors pourquoi dites vous qu
on dit en général puisque défensive
jeudi en général comme je leur ai dit en
particulier les particuliers directeur
jeudi n'a pas reculé
comme on dit en général quand on veut
dire couramment finalement on dit
messieurs les directeurs généraux
pourquoi assiste-t-on deux et ça se fait
couramment général écoutez en face de
façon directeur ou général ce qu'ils ont
dit était bien dit assia c'est aussi
parce que moi qui suis balayeur si
j'avais à faire un discours nommé
directeur sait pas si sûr à trouver mes
mots mais si voyons mais non mais non je
ne suis pas jaloux mais pas chacun sa
spécialité
et je vais vous dire une chose peut-être
qu'après tout monsieur contre point de
vue balayage n'y entend rien du tout et
puis autre chose on peut être tranquille
ce sont les petits comme vous et moi qui
la tenait la troisième chaîne
mais si mais si tenez moi qui tiens ce
ballet s'il veut mais a balayé les ondes
et la chaîne
il reste 1 abbaoui mais ça c'est parce
qu'on est machiniste mais si on était
musicien on l'a tiendra la troisième
chaîne pareil vous ne pouvez pas non je
pense à la musique ne vous dérange pas
non non je t'en prie à quoi pensez-vous
je pense que j'ai pas envie de jouer
pourquoi parce que je suis l'art d'être
un obscur et alors alors tout à l'heure
au moment du solo de violon on va voir
voir quoi on va voir qu'on n'entendra
rien alors je suis désolé de vous
décevoir mais dans ce morceau il n'y a
pas de solo de violon non mes gars sur
le trombone et quel rapport y at il
entre un solo de trombone et violon vous
avez sur les genoux eh bien il ya que ce
violon mais été prêté par le type que
vous voyez là bas avec nos trombone et
alors alors tout à l'heure au moment du
sol au trombone il sera pas s'en servir
mais evp pourquoi il joue du violon non
il joue de la clarinette à l'arrêt qui
appartient violon au type qui joue de la
basse a alors si je comprends bien ce
type qui joue de la basse est un
violoniste qui a prêté son violon au
clarinettiste à qui vous avez donné
votre tombe en échange du galon à peu
près ça sauf que le type qui joue
d'abbas ne joue pas de violons mais
enfin pourquoi tous ces échanges ne
soient d'inauguration pour démontrer que
c'est nous les musiciens qui tenons la
troisième chaîne ouais d'accord souhaité
musiciens mais si on écrit danseurs la
tiendra la troisième chaîne pareils voir
marcel on travaille et on élévation même
être capables mes maîtres qui tiennent
ce soir c'est une libération de la
troisième chaîne faut pas rater pour ma
libération et voyons m vous parlez comme
si j'étais un grand mauvais sujet mais
l'on sait c'est que c'est pour prouver
qu'ils sont les grosseurs la terrestre
encore sous forme de radio aller 1 2 6
il est bien mon gros sujet on n'a jamais
vu ça sur les deux autres chaînes
je descends descends ouais d'accord si
on était danseur mais si on était
pompier pareil
j'aime bien leur métier vous parce que
je viens de dire quoi
des tours qu'est ce que vous avez dit
vous êtes tournon qu'est ce que j'avais
dit avant le thème jeu des sous j'aime
bien votre métier et vous c'est ce que
je vous ai dit vous êtes sourd pourquoi
pour que vous êtes sous non pourquoi
vous aimez bien autre métier parce que
c'est un métier noble ça c'est vrai nous
sommes pompiers de service est un métier
dans lequel on vit sur une grande
échelle
alors question chauffage comme un rite
je vais vous dire on est indispensable à
la télévision
même sur la troisième chaîne même pas
question sur notre présence de monter
jeanne au bûcher par exemple la danse du
feu la mère de madame les flammes sa
vente en un mot sans nous pas de
spectacle fumant exacte du feu à soyaux
subi et u11 moi je suis tout feu tout
flamme
si on était cameramen pareil pourquoi
êtes-vous devenu caméraman parce que à
l'école j'étais sage comme une image
moi ça a toujours été mon objectif à
ulysse a été bercé par le chant des
sirènes moi j'ai été bercé par sont des
caméras je suis d'origine nantaise alors
le gros plan ça me connaît
moi par contre étant entendu military
joel le plan général et leur sens
caméraman porte caméra et sans caméras
de télé et pas de télé pas de troisième
chaîne et qui dit tu remportes troisième
chaîne du 22e ni de première bref on ne
sera pas là ce soir et si on était pour
la soirée bien ils répondent soirée
inaugurale
voilà et bien maintenant silence on
tourne et si on était preneur de son
pareil indispensable qu'on serait on
atteindrait comme ça la troisième chaîne
dans le fond quand j'ai pensé nous
qu'ils en sont la troisième chaîne
commence à nous parce que s'ils avaient
pas preneur de son pour apprendre en
quoi le son vous y en avait pas pas de
quoi prendre son bain on reviendra au
temps du cinéma muet avec m me lie et
par télévisions et pas de preneurs de
sons ou 1,8 million mais l'image
oui mais alors une image chanson c'est
comme un marin son bateau comme un
trapéziste en trapèze comme un esquimau
sans entracte
un pain sans farine panne de quoi faire
une deux sont étudiants ont une image
trouvée dans une autre d'un pêcheur son
poisson à voilà ça c'est une belle image
tenez prenez sa prof gentil mais c'est
une belle image grâce à vous pourquoi
grâce à voir ce que vous m'avez tendu la
perche et si on était
vous êtes fous vous allez nous faire
virer
là
mais qu'est ce que vous regardez là je
regarde l'album de photographies que je
me suis fait pour me souvenir de cette
journée pendant toute ma vie vous avez
beaucoup de photos deux de ces messieurs
guillou le directeur de la troisième
chaîne en train de pousser son landau
voyez là c'est mignon celle là
or monsieur arthur conte avec ses trois
filles pour les deux premières sont déjà
grands d'un troisième est très mignonne
vous croyez qu'ils la drogue mais tu
arrives en chemin de fer sais pas
j'espère en tout cas dans la vie un
troisième enfant c'est très important
oui surtout quand il ya eu deux
auparavant pour incarner une troisième
fallait bien qu'ils en aient eu
auparavant sans ça sera la première
régie et pour une 2e ce soir on fêtera
pour la troisième d'ailleurs tout ce qui
est roi est important exact le 3 est un
chiffre sacré oui regardez vous avez les
sept péchés capitaux les sept plaies
d'égypte où on en est pourquoi citer
vous le chiffre 7 pour nous parler du 3
parce que comme le 12 le 3 et 7 sont des
nombreux sacré exactes sont des nombres
sacré qui selon les zones chimistes et
les teoz of codifie l'harmonie
universelle et que l'on retrouve le plus
souvent dans l'énumération importantes
comme les douze apôtres par exemple les
douze coups de minuit la chanson bien
connue j'ai fait ça en 12
savez vous quelle est la définition du
droit dans le dictionnaire en sept
volumes vrai c'est un plus de noms de
plus un alors si je comprends bien les
deux premières chaînes de télévision
n'ont été créés que pour faire patienter
les futurs téléspectateurs de la
troisième nous n'irons pas jusque là
jusque oblige à penser que vous venez de
dire chiant mais néanmoins il est à
remarquer que depuis la naissance du
monde le 3 a toujours été présent d'une
façon remarquable
les exemples des exemples bien sûr bien
sûr j'ai un fan vous allez par exemple
arrive de 3 à le 5 à 7
non je pense que le provient à faire
dans le cinq à sept si le 3 et celui qui
vient troubler le 5 à 7 des deux oui c
est alors dans l'histoire on rencontre
très très souvent le chiffre 3 par
exemple les trois fils de noé
les trois rois mages les trois évêchés
etes vous les mères d'un nom messe tous
les vers d'un oui parce qu'ils avaient
dans le désordre que le tiercé ou non
parle d'histoire dans votre chevaux et
cheval de troie qu'est ce que c'est que
de l'histoire alors voyez bon je
continue en littérature vous avez les
trois mousquetaires étaient catry mes
trois plus un oui en géographie en
savoie les 3 vallées au canada les trois
rivières les trois épis dans les vosges
et 38 grata au nom du don preuves au
cinéma le troisième homme
les trois lanciers du bengale les 39
marches à 90,39 c'est pas 3 à
attention dans 39 il ya trois et neuf
qui est un multiple de 3 puisque trois
fois d'europe on off
alors d'un côté vous avez 3 à 3 et 1 3
qui précède ce qui fait 4 x 3 et 4 x 3
12 comme les douze mois de l'année
exacte mais revenons aux chiffres 3 puis
alors en mari nous avons deux trois mâts
en vrac les trois orfèvres les trois
valses le prévisionnel les trois
dimensions les trois pyramides
il est trois sergents de la rochelle 4e
était en terme oui et en ce qui concerne
les personnages historiques marquée par
le chiffre 3 ils sont dans la légion
ouais ils sont dans la région
1 ils ont beaucoup oui oui sans beaucoup
aussi richard iii napoléon iii oui du qe
3 1 au quattro et pas 3 trop froid trop
jouer au golf
non je parle de duguay-trouin mais quel
rapport entre du gâteau un chiffre trois
bons on enchaîne alexandre iii pour
qu'on enchaîne à 833 mais non le site
ah qu'est ce qu'il a fait le pont ar oui
oui alors comptez pas vous allez paul
iii qui a fait pas mal de show est gros
moins trois puits pi3 qui n'a rien fait
du tout et terminaux en citant tiers
ministre à l'esprit étroit et bien voilà